[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
sony have revealed the playstation 5
user experience
the interface we'll be using each time
we need our gaming fix
i've watched it through more times than
i probably should have but now i can
give you a list of 12 things you should
know about the playstation 5 ui
first up the home screen the moment you
switch on your ps5
you'll be met by this prompt and then
this home screen
what do you think similar to the ps4
home screen this will feel quite
familiar
panels to represent your games and other
applications
there's also the explore section which
is very similar to the what's new
section we currently use
the screen beneath each card is much
cleaner now and less cluttered
and once again tapping down on the
controller opens up
so much more goodness we'll get to that
in a moment
before we move on from the home screen
check out the playstation store
the big news here is that it's now fully
integrated here
to remind you on the ps4 it was a
separate application
so if we wanted to use it we were forced
to wait
back then that was acceptable but now
it's seven years later and we need a
fully integrated digital store as that's
where many of us buy our games
so let's move on to the control center
and the word of the day
is cards by pressing the playstation
button in game you'll be met with this
layout
a left to right scrolling deck of cards
playstation have focused on barriers to
gamers in this generation
and included quick glimpse cards to see
your level progress
and activities a typical barrier many of
us have is our time
fitting in an hour of gaming on an
evening before someone forces you off
the tv
or your designated time runs out the
first card we see here
is the current mission progress this
person is on which is 33
but the note underneath is what i want
you to look at the level
a big adventure has about 10 minutes
remaining
here's the techie bit the console
constantly analyzes how you play games
to tell you exactly how much time
it expects you to complete the current
mission if you are someone who runs
through games and doesn't pay attention
to anything
or if you are someone who is quite
methodical and looks around always
the ps5 will take this data and give you
its predicted time
to finish the objective you currently
face so the gamer in this demo knows
if they have to leave the house in 20
minutes they have more than enough time
to finish their current goal
and maybe get dressed too so if a
mission says two hours
maybe don't start it at 2am but you do
you
i'm not judging that is not the limit on
cards though oh no no
by clicking on it there is more info
thrust upon us
this will be different for different
games of course but one of the
priorities is to assist
trophy hunters as you know the trophy
system was recently updated
and now on ps5 the games will help you
pick up trophies
letting you know there's a missible
collectible on this stage or even better
still
check this out a video can be played to
help with the objective you are stuck on
you can watch it in game no more
searching google for help and
accidentally having the ending of the
game spoiled
or finding a bad guide and wasting hours
of time
the game makers have the chance right
here to help you out
if they see fit and if you think
clicking between games and videos could
be stressful
then this will help you no end the video
can be pinned using picturing picture
impressive right your game and the video
you're following in the same screen
a good touch for gamers stuck and even
better for those trophy hunters
and by the way what is your trophy level
feel free to flex in the comments below
next we saw the updated notification
system which builds on the limited
interactivity on the ps4
as a friend request or invitation hits
your screen you'll quickly be able to
instantly react
whether that's looking at who's in a
party or instantly joining a friend
if we don't have a mic handy it's not a
problem as the controller on the
playstation 5
has an inbuilt microphone quickly
calling out to a friend you need five
minutes to finish what you're doing
before grabbing a better microphone and
i know this may be an issue just in case
you think having a microphone on the
controller is worrying
it can also be muted it's not a
government conspiracy
but i don't think it is it could be it
could let's just move on
going back to the ps4 for a moment did
you ever watch streams there
i personally wasn't a fan and it looks
like many other gamers weren't too but
playstation have made note of this
and updated the functionality gamers in
the same chat can now screen share
if you spend much time on discord you've
likely seen this in action
it's essentially like streaming but to a
smaller group of people
and not the entire globe the ps5 has a
cool little gimmick here
watching a friend's game play can happen
whilst you stay in your own game
it's another use of that card
functionality pinning the picture on
screen or moving the card around
to not interfere with your game if
you're waiting for a friend to finish
i don't know a game of rocket league
before joining them it's now super easy
to keep an eye on them
whilst not losing any time and keeping
gaming or maybe you simply want to watch
a friend play whilst you get some daily
gaming grinding done
the possibilities are many back in
control center and once we are in a
party
more options become available for
example should a friend crack open a
multiplayer game
the option to join them will be here hop
in and in a matter of seconds
he'll be in the game together the final
thing we saw was about media
as many of you know the share button has
evolved into the create button
and during this demo a 4k photo was
taken in game in real time before they
all jumped into the game and started
playing
what's interesting on this one is that
recently created media
whether that's image or video is
available via the card system here
recently created the photo then can be
edited and text applied to it before
sharing it to social media or to your
friends
all without leaving the game you are in
and the final wow moment is linked to
this
remember the controller has a mic built
in well you can use that to dictate a
message
on the ps5 oh in fact there's another
thing damn i should have said 13 things
oh well
if the friend you are sending the video
or image to has not played the game or
activity in question
the message will come with a spoiler
warning i love that
this is completely dictated by the
developer of the game who may feel
spoiling a game boss is a big deal
and thus slapping a big spoiler warning
over the top of it
pretty damn cool so there we have it 12
things that i think are worth your
attention about the playstation 5 user
interface
i hope you found this useful and if
you're still here please take this dead
joke
and while you're friends with it do you
know what the last thing my grandfather
said before he kicked the bucket he said
grandson
watch how far i can kick this bucket
sorry no
sorry i'm adam from playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
[Music]
time
[Music]
you